tonight I achieved a million subscribers
at
YouTube uh I'm on the island of San
Maran in the Caribbean where people
speak French English Creole and other
languages it's a lovely place to be it's
an ideal climate it's unbelievably
beautiful and
peaceful and how come I got to a million
subscribers I think more than anything
it's because people want a constructive
positive message we're surrounded by
negativity our social media push
negativity at us in fact we can all
achieve so much within ourselves and for
others if we just believe in that
ability if we pursue things of interest
to us and I thank the people who have
subscribed to my channel I'm going to
continue putting out videos and remember
if you want to learn a language you
can